joe biden has confirmed more judges  than trump  obama and george w bush  at this point in their respective  presidencies it is not the supreme court  that's absolutely true  but it is of massive massive importance  business insider and others talking  about this how uh biden out did trump  obama and george w bush in confirming  federal judges by this point in office a  feat overshadowed by war and inflation  and it has been  joe biden has confirmed more federal  judges at this point in his tenure than  any president since jfk  biden's court picks have also been the  most racially ethnically and gender  diverse  but his judicial winds have been  overshadowed by news of inflation war  and the fbi mar-a-lago search this is a  major major deal